a lot of you have been asking me to  address the latest controversy trending  topic even though i personally have no  relationship to said topic and couldn't  be less knowledgeable about it and while  i don't want to speak for those involved  i'm going to  first off this is a complicated topic  second the offending person and or group  and or corporation has the right to  express what they are expressing it is  hard to say what is right or wrong about  anything said controversy slash trending  topic slash unfortunate situation  scandal is truly multifaceted there are  no winners here i hope that by  discussing this topic i can add nothing  to the conversation while neither  defending nor indicting any parties  involved everything happens for a reason  but sometimes things happen for no  reason at all